today on alternative views we were very
happy to have with us a meal deantonio
the filmmaker who has made the film on
McCarthyism point of order the film on
the Kennedy assassination rushed to
judgment the film on the Vietnam War in
the year of the pig the film on Nixon
the Millhouse and many other films
tomorrow we're going to interview the
Antoniou on his films and plan to
produce a series of programmes on his
work as a filmmaker today however we
want to discuss his political views in
particular how he views George Bush in
relationship to the other right-wing
Republican political figures they spent
much of the last past decades studying
and criticizing how would you evaluate
him
well one Hickland I started a book of on
Bush and we did a tremendous amount of
research and III think that it has to be
said at the outset that George Bush is
not a wimp it would be easy for people
on the left or progressives or Democrats
or any number of combination of those to
dismiss with Bush once and for all by
saying he's a wimp but he's not and to
misjudge the enemy is maybe worse than
having no opinion at all because I don't
think that you become a naval pilot and
get shot down and then fly more
emissions in fact quite a few more
emissions and I don't think that you are
as tough as he is I don't think the
reason that he is to me ultimately
dangerous is the year 1957 when he took
over the CIA 7575
I mean I just twisted the number after
ah actually 76
yeah 76 s that's the corrector isolate
weekend why don't you just start over
the oh I'd rather have the mistakes with
you that's fine I mean I think the
stakes are part of life
I mean I leave a lot of hours in but
some of them are so egregious we have
alright anyway but go ahead this is fine
I think that when Bush became a director
of the CIA in 1976 he was charged with
one thing which was to put that show
back on the road to clean it up to make
it tough again and he did that and in
1980 when he ran for president there
were over 180 CIA former officers who
wore Bush buttons and went all over the
country wherever he ran wherever he was
speaking and supported him into the New
Hampshire primary when he finally did
blow it but for some of these the people
who the you know the worst Mad Dogs that
the Carter Administration and Stansfield
Turner had kicked out that's who they
were they were indeed the Mad Dogs that
the CIA is composed pretty largely of
one kind of Mad Dog or another I mean it
isn't exactly the Boy Scouts or the
ladies village improvement society but I
think that Bush has been underestimated
throughout one thing is that he has what
might even be called an upper class
demeanor that softness that many upper
class people affect is frequently
misinterpreted as weakness well he came
up through this upper-class network of
social clubs and schools and also he he
was a right in there with the rest of
them in this regard I think that he
separated himself from a part of his
class by going to end over instead of
st. Paul's or st. Mark's a gratin which
are the more social schools and over is
probably the best United States at that
time prep school for men on for boys
only now it's co-educational but Andover
was a school which emphasized mind and
emphasized the ability to deal with
books and mathematics etc and I don't
think Bush was a genius or anything I
don't think he was all that smart
but he was smart enough to do reasonably
well at
and it's a very hook it's a very hard
school it still is it's still the
hardest repair Ettore school in the
United States to end it's the hardest
one to add her and more of its graduates
go on to Harvard and Yale than almost
and then it than any other prep school
in the United States so it's a class huh
I'm sorry oh no it's it is part of a of
a class structure and a class education
and something that leads you to have a a
mild rather than a loud or aggressive
voice and I think people come frequently
construe an upper-class quiet
moderate voice as weakness which of
course it isn't as I say you're not a
Navy pilot you don't clean up the CIA
and you don't conduct the rough and just
even dishonorable campaign that he
conduct against a caucus without being
somewhat of a tough guy
so the bush is really a serious member
of the upper class he wasn't a Playboy
he wasn't for the list it was also the
son of the senator senator Prescott who
had an enormous influence on him and who
who sort of preceded him along the
political path but he later
Halla can we talk a little bit about
bush's family their relation to his
father you know that his grandfather too
began his own company out in ohio and
was successful so that prescott bush his
father went to private schools went to
yale and the most important thing that
happened to Prescott Bush in Yale is the
most important thing that happened to
say also to Bill Buckley and to George
Bush Prescott Bush became a member of
skull and bones it's impossible to
understand what Skull and Bones is and
what its thrust is unless you've really
looked at it pretty hard it's an
extremely secret senior Society which
means you were tapped literally attempt
to join Stalin bones you were about ten
members of the senior class are tapped
at the beginning of the senior year
some are official the editor of the Yale
Daily News the captain of the football
team and then some people who have
exhibited leadership qualities toughness
and it's an extremely tight strange
group in which an allegiance is sworn
among each other that is far beyond his
pledge of allegiance to the flag of the
United States
it goes beyond family because your
family is left behind in a sense you go
forward with Skull and Bones it's not an
accident that when Bush was vice
president he had a dinner in the White
House for about 40 members of skull and
bones skull and bones is his secret it's
like the original German student
societies the initiations are harsh some
people think the initiations are
homosexual even as well as being harsh
but every member of skull and bones
helps another and it's it's a prime
loyalty it's a it's a perfect upper
class construct and it changes every
person who goes through it now Bush's
father was in it now Bush's father there
are two kinds of secrecy I think in the
United States that the average person
knows nothing about one is the secrecy
of a major private bank now a private
bank isn't like Chase Manhattan Bank
it's not like one of the big Texas banks
which is owned by stockholders and
shareholders a private bank is owned by
no women by a small group of men the
partners sometimes or as few as 15 or 20
and Prescott Bush was a member of Brown
Brothers Harriman investment banks
investment banks I was telling Doug
earlier that one example of the power
Brown Brothers back in 1905
the currency of Nicaragua the five
centavo note had on a picture of a
bearded gentleman who was none other
than James Brown of Brown Brothers he
wasn't a Nicaraguan he was the man who
loaned money to Nicaragua at usurious
rates of interest and it's a kind of
loan that was guaranteed to break the
back of any small third-world country
that did not have an Indian industrial
society and brown brothers did this they
were international bankers each partner
had a private sort of cubicle and it was
a partnership in the purest sense of
that word and that the profits at the
end of the year were divided among the
partners and the better the better of
the those who were inferior to them were
then given bonuses but the bulk of the
money was split
so Prescott Bush was extremely rich and
he lived in a city of great richness
Greenwich Connecticut and he trained his
children in silence and this is
important when you think of George Bush
and he was a member of skull and bones
as well so that when Bush became when
Bush went to Yale and became a member of
skull and bones he was well groomed and
well trained and well rehearsed in all
of that by the time he was at Yale his
father was a senator and his father had
an extraordinary interest in and
function in intelligence affairs so you
have something that's rare in this
country which is a long history in
intelligence out of Maine a long history
of intelligence but in intelligence and
to me the gravest mistake this country
is made in my long life it's not because
I'm against Bush although I am against
Bush but the gravest mistake this
country has made is to elect a former
CIA chief President of the United States
I think it's wrong to have the head of
the secret police
of the foreign secret police President
of the United States because he has an
oath and a loyalty to the CIA and its
many many criminal acts that transcends
his sense of duty or his obligation to
the country as a whole and the people as
a whole well he yeah he will this has
been indicated by his involvement with
the CIA and all of the drug operations
in relationship to the Central America
and South America well certainly I mean
Bush was involved in that as vice
president and as president he's denied
it I don't find out that particularly
alarming I mean this is what one would
expect you could not expect Bush to
admit that he was involved in drugs you
can't expect Bush to admit that he was
connected with the drugs in Panama when
he's just failed in a coup to have
Noriega bumped off Noriega killed his
predecessor by putting a bomb in his
plane his predecessor was an interesting
man graham greene the english writer
went there and wrote a book called i
think a visit to a dictator but but he
was a benign dictator and he tried to
help the people of his country Panama
but Noriega had him had a boss I said
put a bomb in his personal airplane and
he blew up in midair and Noriega took
over and it seems to me that if our
country had been reasonable we would
have had a certain reluctance to make a
policy of accord with a man who had just
murdered his predecessor Noriega as you
know is a high living big spender who
was in drugs from the beginning and all
of our intelligence people knew it that
he was regarded as a stable we have
always looked for stable right-wing
dictators in Central and South America
that is our pond
and we reaped what we sowed we ended up
by getting Noriega well he was also a
CIA asset that intelligence chief and he
was on the payroll he was on a fiat
payroll of the CIA he worked for the CIA
and under Noriega something happened of
great significance that tends to be
omitted which is there are more banks
now in Panama then there are at all as
any single country its size in the world
and that includes Liechtenstein and the
banks all had to do with the drug
business and Noriega has a piece of all
of those things and that could not have
happened without the knowledge of George
Bush in 1976 when he was head of the CIA
head of the CIA and as he met with he
bought two or three times well I mean he
denies ever having met well again so
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
which I don't really but let's just for
the sake of it though he admits there's
on record he's on record he met twice
but he denied it anyway but what you
have that's just as important is Bush
meeting with him is his chief deputy
when he was head of the CIA was the men
and Admiral Daniel Murphy number two
person in the CIA who met with Noriega
frequently an admiral in 1982 when
rippln Bush was vice president he was
appointed a head of the South Florida
Drug Task Force his deputy there was
again Admiral Daniel Murphy Murphy made
many trips to Noriega and that was the
time which you had the real burgeoning
of banks
I mean Panama had no reason to have many
banks the people were poor people there
was a small upper class and the
Americans who were there had their own
banks and their own compound so that
suddenly banks became very popular
because all tons and tons of drug money
were being emptied into Panama and we're
not talking about just mom-and-pop banks
we're talking about now we're talking
about very big
the big New York walleston The Wall
Street in New York banks of course are
the banks that finally serviced all this
money the money would go into a
Panamanian bank and then it would be
wired to New York and then it would go
somewhere else we saw this in our own
country in Miami Miami was never
particularly noted for banks until the
drugs system became fully operational
and then you know there are all those
stories which are true of people going
into a bank in Miami with a with a
bushel basket or a paper sack three feet
high full of hundred dollar bills and
say deposit this and the bank would
charge them immediately two percent for
counting it and two percent of a hundred
thousand dollars is two thousand dollars
for an hour's work and then instead of
paying interest they would charge them
to hold the money so that every you know
the whole great thing about the drug
business is that everybody made out
except the poor user of drugs but the
banks made out the drug the big dealers
made out the little dealers made out and
the sucker on the street who used
cocaine and all the rest of it he didn't
do too well it's significant to note
that the nation published an article on
the political economy of cocaine and
they indicated that before George Bush
took over as drug czar when he was vice
president for Reagan that the federal
government was cracking down on these
banks was stopping drug trade by
regulating the banks and stopping the
flow of drug money as soon as Bush
became drug czar in 1982 they stopped
this policy they went into interdiction
they went into trying to capture boats
off of Florida to patrol the border
along Mexico and this just helped the
big cocaine cartel that could smuggle in
the drugs into this country and that had
the wherewithal to do it and then had
free banks oh there's no doubt about
that and and without that without the
banks the drug event industry would have
died because they really needed banks to
accept and launder the money and large
proper US banks did precisely that
uh it it's not an accident of course
that all that money was then recycled in
one form or another to go back and help
the Contras well this is the other link
here the reason the Reagan
administration and Bush were so tolerant
the big drug dealers and people like
Noriega who were obviously involved in
drug trafficking but we're also helping
them with an illegal supply operation to
the Contras this seemed to be the
obsession of the Reagan administration
that Bush went along with completely we
saw an article I forget which was a one
in Playboy or some others series of
articles where they said that in order
to get Noriega to play ball with them
nori and to keep from to give Noriega
protection and immunity from being
hassled and arrested perhaps or
assassinated he had to agree to give a
certain percentage two or three percent
whatever off the top of his gross
receipts to support the Contras and so
that's one of the reasons that Noriega
said I've got Bush by the balls it's I
thought it was so funny all during this
business of the failed coup in Panama
where they said gosh why did enjoy Bush
just go in there and get Noriega and
bring him out and put him on trial you
know this is terrible issue that's a
last thing George Bush wants to do is to
put Noriega on trial but the mistake and
push on the other hand is almost as bad
as a trial in the sense that Noriega has
a hold on this country and on this
administration and it's got to be
deposited in a Swiss bank somewhere plus
in his own mind and tongue and he has
the capacity to blackmail a fair number
of major US players including I would
suspect the president of this country
for sure Daniel Murphy and many others
to me one of the most pathetic things
most mother was pathetic events in our
time a recent time with the Kerry
hearings which was the most exciting and
dramatic hearing I've seen on television
since Watergate or since the army
McCarthy hearings and it was relegated
to a cable channel it was relegated to
CNN c-span c-span
and which is a very you know a channel
most people do not watch and you can't
watch it unless you have cable and these
hearings went on the the outcome is
published in four before four though the
outcome is published in four volumes
which you can buy from the US Government
Printing Office but you see these young
Americans on camera to see a young Cuban
on camera who's saying well I was in my
Learjet at takeoff Kerry said how much
money to have waiting to do oh I don't
know five point four mil I was on my way
down to Panama and the police arrested
me and they took my money and I've been
given 30 years and that's why I'm
talking hoping to get a smaller sentence
then to see an American a young
good-looking American guy maybe 24 25
say I started running a little boat of
down to Central America and eight maybe
into Colombia I'd get marijuana and I
made you know thirty thousand dollars on
one trip then I got a bigger boat I made
five hundred thousand dollars and then I
realized that marijuana really wasn't
the right drug to bring in anyway so I
bought an airplane and I learned how to
fly I used to fly into Colombia and I
would bring in and these people were
flying right into the u.s. one after the
other these people were finally arrested
but all of them had one two three years
experienced one person who was arrested
was a transplanted Cuban who worked out
of the Barbados not Barbados the island
right across Cuba Jamaica no anyway but
anyway Harmon Porter Bahamas absolutely
there's a whole chapter on the Bahamas
this is Mohammed was considered the
great drug import center for the whole
United States for the entire United
States and one of these people said well
you know I used motor boats small fast
motor boats
don't from the Bahamas right into my
hammock he said you know on a Sunday
afternoon there are 50,000 boats out
there the family down as nobody else has
a boat so I have 10 boats filled with
drugs so if one of my guys got busted
what I could buy him out after a few
months of paying well but nine would get
through so now Bush and company are
worried about the drug problem they were
part of the drug problem right they were
in the drug business the CIA was in the
drug business the very heart of the CIA
was to save drugs for money for guns and
the guns was to support the Contras
against the legitimate government of
Nicaragua and this has been going on a
long time there's no greater disease in
American life and the madness of Adi
communism because Nicaragua was never a
threat to the United States
it was never communist and it was never
truly communist if you think that Cuba
is communist Cuba how could Cuba be a
threat to the United States our radar is
so good that if a plane took off and
came close we blow it out of the sky but
do they have the troops to invade us the
answer's no the United States is also
not understood I think a fundamental
question about most of these countries
which is that they're nationalists more
than they are communists or Marxist
they're nationalists in that the United
States Fidel Castro is the first person
to rule Cuba in modern times modern
history going back 300 years who was a
Cuban first you have the Spanish and
then you have the Americans and then
you're at Phaedo even if you hate Fidel
and I don't but even if you do you have
to admit he's the first Cuban and the
same thing is true in Nicaragua we
bought all those other people in
Nicaragua one president after another we
arm them we gave them great money
personal wealth and Ortega is the first
ruler of Nicaragua
who is truly a Nicaraguan and not
somebody in the pay of the United States
and he's not in the pay of the Soviet
Union which can't afford to pay anybody
very much he's a I would I would call
her taiga a patriot patriot as I would
call most of his enemies people who
represented a bankrupt class which
exploited the rest of the people I'm
making too many speeches I'm you have
some interesting topics to discuss what
I thought we might do now is to go back
and look into the roots of George Bush's
involvement in the Intelligence
Committee community you made an
interesting point that Bush's father and
Bush were members of Skull and Bones
there was a secret society that was
dedicated to secrecy secret bonds oath
and the Bush's training in his family
trained him in secrecy was of primary
value in the banking lists and the
banking business is another secret
organization that his father
participated in at one time you had an
idea that when Bush was involved in
Texas oil business he might have had
intelligence connections and involvement
and indeed his beginning in the Texas
oil business after he returned home from
World War two had some connections with
skullenbones do you want to elaborate on
his young connections I'd like to go
back one step
Bush's father was an officer in the
First World War the 1914 to 1918 war and
part of his training took place at Fort
Sill Indiana Fort Sill Oklahoma where
two of his closest skull and bone front
friends went with him as a young young
officers one of them a key person in
George Bush's life was Neal Mallon by
the way both Prescott Bush and Neal
Mallon not only served in the field
artillery but also in intelligence in
World War one so you have a hereditary
connection to intelligence when they
came out Mallon went to Texas
and with very little money he bought a
piece of a semi bankrupt company that he
formed became one of the big
corporations in Texas the dresser
industries oh yeah
now when George Bush left George Bush
having been a pilot and entered Yale
then having been enlisted as a pilot at
age 18 after having been shot down and
then returning to Yale and taking his
degree decided that he and his wife and
young child would drive to Texas in
their floppy old car and they did and
they sought out Neal Mallon and Neal
Mallon gave George Bush a job in dresser
industries and Bush says in his campaign
autobiography and now and also confirms
it that the job was essentially the
first job was sort of sweeping the place
to learn something about the business
and then going up and then Bush decided
to become an oil player here in Texas
and he with Malins helped he did and
it's no accident than what that when his
next child was born the child was named
Neal Mallon Bush now it is my unprovable
conclusion because you can't prove much
about the activity of intelligence
people the whole gambit is to keep it
secret I think that Mallon who had been
in intelligence in World War one carry
on a kind of freelance intelligence
after World War one and as he built up
dresser industries into being quite an
enormous corporation and I think and I
may be alone in the whole United States
I think that Bush acquired George Bush
acquired sometime in the early 1950s
through Neal Mallon a connection with
the CIA the CIA is something about which
we know nothing
it was constructed that way it's meant
to be that way and it's not very easy
you cannot get anything from the Freedom
of Information Act
the FBI is bad enough I applied to both
CIA and the FBI for any files they might
have held on me the FBI at least gave me
you know quite a few thousand pages but
the CIA would give me many pages in
which everything was blacked out but my
name something I was quite familiar with
so that uh you know there it was they
the CIA never yielded anything and to
this day it is never yielded anything
under the Freedom of Information Act and
to this day its primary concern is
secrecy so you can't ever prove I could
be just a liar and make this up about
bush and they would not deny it
and I can even prove it maybe and they
would not deny it they would have no
comment because the CIA is not stupid
it's clever enough to know the denial
constitutes a form of acceptance of
agreement so they have no answer to give
and if you were to write for the files
of George Bush and the CIA in the 1950s
they would respond with there is no
answer but we did have something that in
1950s with the help of neo Marlon George
Bush founded the Zapata Oil Corporation
we know that that had corporate
headquarters in Texas and was very
active all around the Caribbean
precisely the place that the CIA was
interested in at that time we also know
in 1963 after the Kennedy assassination
a memo turned out from J Edgar Hoover
the George Bush asking him about the
results of his survey of the community
the Cuban exile community and how they
were responding to the to Kennedy
assassination so there's a piece some
evidence at least circumstantial and
actual that links Bush to the
intelligence community during that
period when he was RL man in Texas we
also know that the CIA for many years
has used various organizations
corporations multinational corporations
as either front or just as a source of
information and cooperation so it's not
it's not right it's not a bureaucratic
distinction but those corporations are
regarded as assets
whereas it's my contention that Bush was
an officer and in the CIA language
there's an enormous difference yeah I
mean an asset could be any flag-waving
businessman who you're going to Germany
you're going to open a business there
we'd be interested if you'd report along
these lines you know and then there'd be
certain specific things that we're not
but as an officer you would go in there
with the capability to hire other people
to perform acts even violent acts to
suborn other people to bribe them to
conduct the kind of policy that let's
face it that all intelligence groups
whether they be the US or British or
Soviet or Chinese or Cuban do this is
what intelligence groups do they they
hire people to commit acts of sabotage
it was somebody Bush knew who put a bomb
into a Cuban airplane and killed 53
people it was somebody who had who's
probably a vague asset of the CIA and
Bush's connections as you quite rightly
pointed out with the Caribbean became a
major point of interest for the United
States he's after all Cuba is over there
the other side and as I say this all
seems like something conjectural you
can't prove you can never prove that as
far as a spy and who put him before a
firing squad and he's willing to speak
it but even most spies of quality prefer
to die rather than to say anything this
is the history that the British
established long before we had any spies
let's move towards George Bush's after
he into politics he was the son of
Prescott Bush who is the senator of
Connecticut was a who because a quite
powerful senator his father also went to
Yale as did Bush his father was also in
skull and bones and the whiffenpoof
society as was Bush his father also
played first base for Yale as was big
Bush his father had intelligence
connections in World War
one as we were suggesting Bush did so it
was obviously a big influence of the
father on the son George followed
Prescott footsteps pretty closely
moreover George decided to run for
politics possibly as a CIA asset or
operative moving into the political
field what is your theories about these
connections well he started running for
office in Texas
let's to be as candid as we can from an
oil district right and he failed all
right he was elected after failing he
was elected to Congress but then he
would want it to be elected to the
Senate and he was defeated by Yarborough
who was a liberal Texan then down the
road it looked as if Carrboro
Yarborough's reputation was turning sour
among the people of Texas and Bush
decided to run against him but then out
of the blue appeared our friend who ran
for the vice presidency with Dukakis
against Lloyd Bentsen and who ran
against Yarborough so that Bush having
spent a fortune thinking he was going to
be cure bro I mean Yarber would take the
Democratic nomination and instead Benson
of course beat Yarborough up in the
Democratic primary with a vicious with a
vicious red vicious red-baiting campaign
and then you had the tightest race in
the history of Texas which was Benson
against bush and each one of them
spending more money than anybody had
ever spent to run for the Senate and
Bush lost by now much win by a tiny tiny
number of open I thought I was closest
race ever held for the Senate in the
state of Texas and Benson said Bush was
too liberal and was ensign said that
Bush was too liberal
Bentsen was running as a true
conservative at this point Nixon decided
to help hold young Bush out I can't say
old boy Bush out and he appointed him
ambassador the UN Ambassador for PA he
gave him two appointments first
ambassador to the United Nations and
Bush wasn't very comfortable with that
he didn't like being in New York among
other things then he became ambassador
to China and then he had the job that
was really quite interesting he became
chair of the Republican National
Committee and he was in that job when
watergate broke out and he there are two
famous letters that George Bush wrote to
Nixon one is no matter how this comes
out I will back you to the end and the
second one is it really grieves me to
write such a letter but I would think
you would do more of a service to your
country under your party if you resign
and flip-flopped on that and of course
Nixon left and shortly after that Ford
or a year and a half after that Ford
appointed Bush then to become head of
the CIA which is a curious appointment
the CIA people wanted somebody strong
must have had some experience with the
CIA otherwise you would have to believe
that the CIA which was really under
tremendous problems because of postage
etna activity there were there were
investigations of the Phoenix program as
you know the Phoenix program permitted
one CIA person and one Vietnamese to say
that you were a Vietcong and they could
blow you away and have the right to kill
you it was the right to kill people we
admitted that we killed about 25,000
people in the Phoenix program the
Vietnamese claim it was closer to
400,000 and nobody will know what the
answer is and I suspect myself it was
probably somewhere in between and I'm
not a liberal but
but Bush was then wellis Const into the
heart of the National Republican Party
and he obviously hide the presidency and
in the beginning he was a favorite to
beat Reagan in 1980 well it's also
significant that Bush was the candidate
of the top peopled American power
structure David Rockefeller and all of
those groups been a tremendous number of
CIA people mm-hmm and he had been in the
trilateral commission and he had all
these upper class connections and Reagan
was just this rank outsider with a crazy
man from the right and so that when
Reagan won the establishment folks
freaked out and then tried to come up
with a special arrangement where they
would have Kissinger really running the
country and a Bush up there as the as
the the head man really doing things
behind the scene and Reagan balked at
that so they finally come up with a
compromise where Bush would be vice
president and that turns out that the
not so wimpy Bush as you said turned out
to be the real heavy in the White House
running all of these covert operations
and keeping lying about that I mean Bush
was a very heavy player and that alien
administration what are some of the
things that he was doing well there is
nothing that took place in South in
Central America that Bush was not
involved in and Central America is
really the primary emphasis in that
period it's not only the Contras it was
added Cuban stuff it was a the art war
supporting the government of El Salvador
it is it was essentially South America
and Bush had access to all the CIA
people it was like the head of the CIA
was suddenly planted in the White House
he had Donald Gregg
yet there's nobody sort of wilder in the
history of the CIA who was reporting to
the white to the White House and Bush
then a guy named Rodriguez Felix
Rodriguez Felix Rodriguez as opposed to
chichi and what Felix Rodriguez invented
a new kind of way to kill people in
Vietnam it took a lot of courage
Rodriguez had a lot of guts and he did
the most dangerous work you can think of
and he did it well and it's too bad that
was probably the most immoral idea
anybody ever had but it still took
courage I mean life is a contradictory
idea and it would be great if all the
villains were cowards with a yard and
Rodriguez was a hero in the wrong cause
but what he would do is fly a very light
airplane and he would find VC as they
called it National Liberation Front
positions and he would hang in long
enough to call in the Bombers would then
come in and bomb those positions and
kill the people and he did the same
thing in Central America and he went to
the White House he was a friend of a
close friend of Donald Gregg's who was
Bush's closest friend the man who just
this year was made ambassador to Korea
with a lot of struggle and a lot of but
of course the Democrat Elliott Abrams
long line you told no no Greg skew
Donald reg I mean yeah the Democrats in
the Senate have never been known for
courage because they should have they
should have blocked that nomination 'el
boy I mean Greg was no more fit to be an
ambassador than I am and I was a
communist when I was 16 years old
etc etc etc but so I'm rambling on I
thought the key of that here is that it
was alleged at least in a Rolling Stone
magazine that George Bush was put in
charge of this black eagle operation
there was an illegal supply operation to
the Contras to get them arms that would
circumvent the scrutiny of the Congress
and that he brought in at that time
Donald Gregg Gregg
run this Central America contra supply
operation Greg and turn hired Felix
Rodriguez his old buddy from Vietnam so
you had a CIA military operation being
run out of George Bush's office when
Eugene hasenfus his plane was shot down
who is part of the supply operation in
October of 1986 he had in his notebook
Don Gregor elephants number Felix
Rodriguez and the first person that was
called when the Felix Rodriguez called
when the plane was shot down was gone
Gregg and I guess Sam Watson who is his
assistant took the phone call
Colonel Watson so that the Bush's office
was heavily involved in this illegal
country supply operation that was the
same drug operation is an operation we
talked about earlier with Noriega that
was running illegal drugs well it was
the only way to get money to buy the
arms that would support that would
support our right-wing forces in
Nicaragua I mean it put the white house
itself in the drug business because they
were the arms would go down but then the
drugs are drawn back this is you know
the same plane the most astounding
single tail in the Kerry Commission is
this one pilot who said now where do you
want me he brought down the arms and he
had a whole DC for a four-engine plane
he said where do you want me to land and
they said homestead Air Force Base well
the idea of a pilot landing at Homestead
in Florida which is an United States
Army Air Force Base Arab Army Air Forces
from mine that's world war two drug war
to us that's a Air Force Air Force Base
when he landed there was no prom he
called the tower he was coming in and to
me that almost the greatest cinematic
thing there is is how I used to be a
pilot and when you land there's a truck
there with a big sign that up that says
follow me so there was the Jeep it was
not a truck there was a jeep saying
follow me and it took him into a hard
stand and he parked his
Plane full of drugs and left which would
lead one to assume that somebody
connected with the air force where else
a private contractor came and empties
unloaded what would probably be several
tons of drugs enough to keep the streets
of New York Boston Los Angeles and
Houston going for a long time not to
mention Wall Street South American Wall
Street and in Beverly Hills and the
movie industry and the rich and all the
users of high-grade cocaine and the
irony of this is at the same time Bush's
name drug czar of the Reagan
administration well at the same time
that is Central America operation is
smuggling drugs into this country and
unprecedented numbers he's supposed to
be in charge of the war on drugs at the
Reagan administration or later Bush is
exploited for political ends he was a
true he was truly a drug czar father
yeah well now the Oliver North operation
was going on parallel palace but then
George Bush would have to step in and
cool things when Oliver North was having
trouble with Donald Gregg and Felix
Rodriguez well you know the right wing
of our country always uses the word
conspiracy about those who disagree with
it but if there was ever a first-rate
conspiracy of massive conspiracy in the
history of our country it was in the
White House and Reagan did not we now
know that Reagan had some idea of what
was going on but Reagan was not a
hands-on president he thought he
couldn't even remember the names of his
Secretary of State or high officials he
saw that he wasn't totally connected
with this but he was made aware of it
but there it was in the White House
under George Bush and Donald Gregg and
other senior officers of the State
Department and the CIA and we work and
now we know we are now talking about
drugs in the streets and people dying
and OD'ing
that we have a drug culture beyond
measure but you can't say it began in
the White House but it certainly was
very big in the White House it was the
White House that made it possible had
the Reagan administration really said
this is the end we're going to close it
down it could have been closed and I no
longer think it can be closed down
because there are just too many people
involved I was in Los Angeles at the
home of a person I cannot mention he's a
major player in the film industry and in
his house he has eight or ten
collector's items of 18th century
English silver and each one of them is
filled with the most expensive cocaine
you can buy and it's there for the
guests to take and snuff and this is
standard now I mean not that is standard
but the use of cocaine is standard among
all classes of people in this country
the poor die from it because they get
inferior cocaine they get in some cases
Co candidates being mixed with poison
either intentionally or by mistake and
the rich get very pure first-class
cocaine I don't think there's even
anybody among the young people in this
room who doesn't know somebody who
hasn't used cocaine and you can't say
that Bush is responsible for it I mean
that's too much you can only say that
Bush shares a very profound
responsibility and it's time that he
turned his back on that responsibility
it may be too late to stop it but it's
not too late to make an effort it's it's
absurd that now as president of the
United States Bush declares another war
the war on drugs because he was so
responsible for having connections with
so many players in the drug world when
he was Reagan's vice president of course
it gives them a good opportunity to do
away with a lot of civil liberties and
do away hopefully with a lot of
opposition I hope that explains what I
said how would you evaluate the mass
media coverage of all this that we've
been talking about Howard Lee Howard Lee
basically what do you think that is here
enormous story far bigger than Watergate
ever was
and yet they hushed it up well I think I
think the main reason for that is class
interest frankly and they are the people
who put bush in the media people they're
the people who supported bush and who
supported Reagan and in a sense is to
admit their own culpability in a in a
reflexive secondary way but nonetheless
a kind of culpability and is to admit
error which the press and the media that
the media no longer admit area
I mean error TV has gone soft and the
great gray papers like the New York
Times and The Washington Post that they
don't deal with this The Times would
have an occasional page tenth story
about the Contras and drugs where they
said the sources were merely convicted
drug dealers as if the story really
didn't have all that much credence to it
and they never connected Bush with all
this well to me if I go back to the
Kerry Commission Kerry Committee the
Kerry committee report is as good a
report on drugs as will be made by this
government and it's a first-class report
and it covers everything it covers the
Bohemians it covers a cell of Central
America thinking it covers Colombia it
covers Americans it covers all kinds of
people who have flown back and forth
it covers pilots and big-time
distributors people who owned many many
planes etc and nobody nobody picked up
on this as I said it was broadcast on
c-span it would appear as a small story
in the New York Times and Washington
Post but the basic thrust of what Kerry
uncovered is still there it should be
and it was published by the obviously by
the Government Printing Office in a
small printing and very few people
brought it you can still pick up the
phone now and order the four volumes and
they are staggering you have enough
there to bring down a government and and
Kerry himself seems to have lost his
courage
and he's a very brave man carry but he
seems to have lost something I mean I
know one of the reasons and you hate to
say this in public so I won't oh don't
you laugh I will I mean his wife and
children left him I mean because he was
having an affair with a major Hollywood
star Michelle Pfeiffer and it took away
some of his efficiency but Carrie was
remarkable he was the most decorated
naval officer in the in the Vietnam War
and the first thing he did when he came
back home was joined Vietnam Veterans
Against the War and that's a remarkable
position I mean you know it takes
courage to fight in a war but it takes
more courage to come back and do that
and then to have the skill to be elected
to the Senate in the state of
Massachusetts was an extraordinary
achievement and to do the hearings was
an extraordinary achievement and to let
them drop makes you wonder you know is
he being people see him as a new Jack
Kennedy people see him as a presidential
candidate see the media completely
ignored him so he immediately needed to
pursue this to the maximum he might have
been bumping his head against the wall
because he wasn't getting any response
the media completely covered this up
well I want to know what was wrong with
America it was that he was his show
going on not c-span but the CN I mean
c-span seen by the smallest possible
audience that the other media ABC NBC
CBS never picked up by they would have
the slightest reference to it it was it
was as big as the army McCarthy hearings
is his biggest Watergate and when people
say the war on drugs etc etcetera this
is the greatest menace to the strikes at
the very heart of this country I mean
this is only two years ago why didn't
somebody just what even today why
doesn't George Bush if he believes in
the war on drugs pick up the carry
Commission report committee report and
out to the American people why aren't
five million copies distributed that
hame to cut the crunches off they'd have
to close it or cut Daniel Murphy off and
these are Bush's pets Bush has been
deeply involved in his controverts the
greatest reading is the funniest reading
there's a 500-pound arms dealer in Miami
Namie neonguy weighs 500 pounds he has a
huge palace on the grounds of the Miami
International Airport
when Daniel Murphy wanted to borrow a
plane to go to see nerrit Noriega he
goes to see the arms dealer and the arms
dealer says to him and in both of them
testified of this in the Kerry
Commission Murphy is it has no qualms
about testifying the arms dealer says to
him well last time I loaned you the
plane this time I can lend it to you
you've got to pay for the gas
you know it's a four engine plane so the
gases for $5,000
so Murphy takes it down to Panama seized
Noriega and he's got a business guy with
him and then they they fly back now
could this have nothing of course Murphy
was number two in the South Florida drug
task force under George Bush this is
1982 how could he do that you know you'd
think that some reporter somewhere would
write an article about it nobody said
anything the Panamanian said nothing we
said nothing and the more we talk about
a free press they're free to advertise
they're free to sell but they don't
print like a free press they don't
publish like a free press and you could
say to me well if you don't like this
country won't you go somewhere else well
this is my country and I love this
country I may despise its government I
may despise the CIA and the FBI but this
is my country I would like somebody I
wish somebody had said at that moment
this is time to do something about the
drug world starting with Daniel Murphy
maybe with George Bush surely with the
arms dealer and surely with the guy who
flew the airplane and the Contras and
the Contras and all the rest of them the
CIA and all the rest of that wretched
machine but no that becomes our real
government